you les gars et michou nobs tag
carrément ensemble on est l'ardent tweet
tissu allongé sur une lambo comme ça
[Musique]
c'est pas trop qui a poussé l'habitation
pas un gardien de premier avec nbc
l'année longue
ça va être de faire arrêter là
les garages ou tiff jours qui vous fait
des bisous olala inox
regardez là en fait un bienvenue sur le
clip de michou et inox savait-il dernier
lors d'une folie ined stuart à comme
d'habitude à kaya dori tourner carrément
ensemble
sur le tournage
merci rockstar gta en séminaire dans le
sud à marseille et
et en fait moi je faisais un ne paie
donc je faisais des sons etc et inox et
il est passé à marseille pour clip et
funky noxa à la cci duke où il est passé
pour clip est un de ces sons et me suis
dis des gros t'es là vient au studio il
a posé un petit employé lire et on a
tapé un délire héros après caby mais on
a passé 80 s et ça c'était car ils
remercient brut il apte au mans merci
brut ticket pour une voix de las vegas
qui est bien aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
s'est privatisé du coup un bateau
virtuel
ces nouvelles technologies qui utilisent
dans le cinéma actuellement ou même dans
les séries pour recréer des décors sans
avoir besoin de voyager au look good on
par exemple on a une superbe plage
privée et le concept du clip le concept
principal c'est qu'en fait on a tout le
monde du clip on a inox en fait qui nous
fait galérer sur le tournage on attend
on contourne bijoux et elle est tout le
temps à l'heure mais inox qui s'est
vraiment le restaurant personnes
occupent un plus dans la veille à ces
même pas moi je suis en retard wada
matelas dans la vraie vie la sueur qui
faisait chars et ils auront peut-être
passé pour lui l'état à l'heure de jeu
oui j'avais pas qualité pour moi c'était
plus comme d'habitude en fait enfin que
ça qu'on va faire des playbacks a de la
gueule
[Musique]
et la séduction
ça sur un steinway chez eurostar et la
chaudière chien star sur un steinway je
suis au stade où tu peux lire faible au
regard des bons mètres le début que
c'était lourd de ouf on dit voilà j'ai
mal j'ai su tout seul bon on garde
d'armes de première mais celle là les
lourdais au programme jusqu'au là ça
serait super bien jusqu'en à vraiment me
vraiment en retard tels but ou pas vous
avez 7 concepts entre de rockstar une
qui est toujours à l'heure assidu
excédera et l'autre qui tout en retard
mais là non vraiment on est vraiment en
retard mais celles qui étaient assidus
c'est elle qui nous a vraiment mis
vraiment en retard on en retard oui on
est carrément habillé en mode rock star
on est prêt pour clip et rochers trop
chaud change de fou j' ai trois bolides
de foot devant moi j'ai un robot par
lewandowski chez même pas il sort d'où
on fait ça devant moi incroyable là je
suis dans un film en fait les gars vous
voyez les trois voitures est en fait sur
chaque voiture je vais en une fois tiens
je vais être quatre fois sur le même
plan sans fond vers la technologie du
robot j'espère je me trompe pas mais non
il m'a dit qu'il m'avait il m'avait
validé en fait le robot dans la vraie
vie
le caméraman il effectue des mouvements
et du coup c'est jamais même nous manque
si tu veux faire un moment du coup pour
pouvoir avoir le même mouvement ils ont
dû prendre un robot est comme ça ils
n'ont pas besoin de fonds vert ils
peuvent faire les masques de détourer
etc
et comme c'est tout un même mouvement
ils ont pas de souci il superpose des
calques frein dossier classé par les
obligations contre la discrimination ou
validés par latex et quart
on a rappelé georges pourrait même pu
faire pour que tu puisses mais bon moi
j'ai aussi roulé dessus
mais classé comme sarthois de 14 il doit
tuer pathé personnes je mets comme ça
ouais comme ça c'est si au moins on voit
on voit regardes tu me dis tu allongé
sur une lambo comme ça la boîte barberis
et sur la proche tu es là mais je suis
dans ce [ __ ] j'ai pas sur le dernier
s'il belgique a pas ce qui me sera
proche de moi énervé bon fin de la
journée
c'était cool scénariste est carrément
carrés dans laxe merci nous avons suivi
cette rude carrément vous êtes pauvre
êtes magnifique sur ses pas côtières les
internautes vous êtes magnifique cette
journée magnifique on peut partir sur
est vachement ce héros c'est pas mal
aujourd'hui on est des retards juste
aujourd'hui
[Musique]